hello everyone and welcome to the
penultimate round of this year's Norway
chess it is bookish versus sariantari
and it is the only game that was
resolved In classical time format all
the other games went to Armageddon and
it's absolutely incredible what happens
in this game uh how the pawns got where
they got is beyond me uh you guys will
just have to see and uh well and believe
it so let's check it out Lucas has the
white pieces and he opens four Pawn to
D4 uh We're Not Gonna discuss what
happened in the other games as some of
the games are still being played while
I'm recording this and I will make at
least one more video from round eight
and then we are going to discuss the
understandings and the pairing so the
four way of Knight to F6 uh Bishop to F4
now opting for a sort of a London system
setup we have the five Pawn to E3 G6 and
now Knight to F3 by gukash with Bishop
to G7 and Knight B to D2 We have castles
and pawn to C3 so a pretty pretty
standard setup with uh Pawn to B6
preparing to feed and get to the light
Square bishop and there is again game
that reached this position or rather
there are a couple of games for example
Levon arunian is a big fan of this exact
setup he defeated Hans Neiman twice here
with Bishop to E2 and there is even a
game that he lost to Fabiano Cortana but
here we have pawned the H for baigukish
and it is now as of move 7 that we have
a completely new game so this exact same
setup would fall into H4 has not been
played before even though uh Ponte H4 is
a well-known movie in a similar
structures so upon to C5 they say that
the best reply to an attack on the flank
is the strike in the center uh Knight to
E5 and now Knight B to D7 sort of
inviting Knight to C6 but even if this
is played you don't really care Queen T8
and okay black is perfectly fine so it
does happen in the game only a few more
moves were played upon the two upon the
H5 stopping any future H5 ideas from
White and only now Knights the C6 the C7
square is covered by the bishop so Queen
back to E8 and now Pawn to B4 gookish
not messing around he knows is what the
best movie is in pretty much all of the
positions uh Knight the G4 now and okay
we have Castles by hookash and now Pawn
to E5 here you don't have to rush Pawn
D5 you could also just develop for
example Bishop to B7 then B5 A6 A4 and
then for example Pawn to E5 so if you
think that it benefits your possession
but he doesn't he plays Pawn to E5 right
away and now Bishop back to G3 we have
Queen to E6 now attacking the Knight and
now you advance the pawn to B5 so Pawn
to B5 Bishop to B7 doesn't seem like
there's a way for you to uh to avoid
losing a pawn but this is what bookish
probably has all planned out he plays
Pawn to C4 and we are getting very close
to the position from the thumbnail
Bishop captures and c6b captures and now
do Capron C6 with the queen or not well
it's not that simple if you capture with
the queen then comes C characters on D5
and now you can't capture back so is
this something you want to allow because
if you capture back version to have
three picks up the rook and A8 so it's
not uh it's not great so instead after B
captures on C6 Knight D2 F6 by tari and
now Pawn to E4 and this is something you
don't see very often uh having uh uh a
type of structure like this when you
have so much tension in the center is
rare but it does happen from time to
time but having this uh you just don't
have this I mean it's so much tension
that it has to be resolved right away
now there's a a few moves you could
consider here you could capture an E4
with the pawn you could capture with the
Knight or you could play Queen captures
on C6 which is kind of the the worst
option we're gonna discuss what happens
if D captures an E4 because in the game
Knight captures and E4 was played B
captures and E4 is the safest uh point
being that after Pawn to D5 which looks
incredibly scary you have you you can
move the queen queen d8 and now after
let's say Bishop captures Knight
captures and Knight captures and E4 uh
black can launch forward with the pawn
spawn knock on the Knight to G5 you're
going to push even further upon the F4
attack the bishop once the blusher moves
even Pawn to E4 you attack the rook and
once The Rook moves even Pawn to E3 and
the black has sufficient compensation
however after born the E4 daddy played
Knight captures on e4 and this is not
much much different C captures on D5
Queen captures and now you force the
queen to E4 freeing up the path for the
white d-pawn to March forward a queen
captures on e4 was played and now upon
the D5
and now if you look at this position uh
this is much much uh different than the
position we discussed where the black
pawn ends up on E3 so this is much much
different than uh than uh this after
Pawn to D5 was played obviously much
this is much better for white so okay
Knight to F6 uh the Knight Returns and
now Bishop to F3 chasing away the queen
queen to F5 and now Pawn to D6 and now
look at this it's only move 22 uh
gookish already has opponent C6 and Pawn
on D6 and those are past pawns so this
is something I mean uh in in the olden
days you would just resign here you you
might even consider pulling a bar delay
in here but uh okay this is uh 2023 you
never resigned and of course tari
continues he played Pawn to E4 attacks
the bishop Bishop to E2 and now Knights
the D5 so okay he continues fighting but
now just Rook the C1 and now the problem
is okay Rook C uh one uh stops Knight to
C3 even though you can play it because
as the bishop defends the C3 square if
you play it you can even just capture I
mean the pawns are unstoppable you you
really don't care what uh tari is doing
at this point let's say Pawn to C7 there
there's no move you can make I mean D7
is covered by the queen so this is
happening even if you block the queen
with the bishop so now you cover D7 like
this then Bishop B5 uh D7 happening next
this is Unstoppable uh so instead Knight
to B4 was played and now Pawn to C7
gokish just going all out here Bishop to
D4 and now Queen to A4 guarding the D7
square with the queen uh we have Ponte
A6 preparing B5 but uh gookers doesn't
care he finds it pawn to D7
and now there's just no way uh to
prevent queening upon the B5 was played
which is uh you know uh nice uh just by
looking at it but it doesn't really work
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the only series of moves that win
for gookish uh while I give you a couple
of seconds
[Music]
foreign for those of you who were able
to do it Congratulations by not being
fooled by that uh post B Pawn and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Bishop captures on B5 of
course we're gonna sacrifice Our Queen
but we don't care because we will get
another queen uh there's no uh reply to
this uh ba capture some B5 was played
and now of course Queen captures an A8
and now the problem is if you capture
it's a very simple win just spawn to d8
with check and that's it you have to
capture another queen comes into the
game and now white is up the exchange
and up a full Rook so you have a a rook
for a knight and also a rook for nothing
so that's I mean of course the instant
resigns so instead after Queen captures
an A8 daddy played Queen captures on D7
which is sort of still playable but
Lucas plays this out like an engine
Queen captures an E4 Knight captures an
A2 and now Rook C the E1 preparing Queen
t7 to just dominate the position
completely so Bishop to F6 is stopping
this and now Rook back the D1 chasing
away the Queen Bishop to D4 and now
Queen to C2 and this queen to C2 is such
a slap in the face that uh I'm sure even
you guys felt it you know just watching
this video because the Knight is hanging
and if the Knight moves uh of course you
know what what happens if the Knight
moves the B4 Queen captures on C5 that
that's what happens of course yeah now
if Bishop captures The Rook captures on
D7 and there's nothing for you to play
for so after Queen to C2 we have Queen
to E6 and now Rook after E1 just you
know the the moves are basically playing
themselves at this point Queen to C4 and
gookish happily trades Queen captures on
C4 B captors and now Bishop to D6 this
bishop to D6 is completely winning but
I'm just gonna show you another fun line
because it's like an instant win Rook to
B1 there's no defense against Rook the
B8 regardless of uh what you play it's
just one of those positions
uh but uh yeah even uh without this you
could also play Rook captures on D4 uh
uh even even uh Rook to B1 is fine but
okay you could block with Knight to B4
but this is even more forcing for
example C captures on D4 and now Rook to
B1 now you don't even have to worry
about Knights the B4 and now Rook to The
Rook to B8 is Unstoppable so instead
Bishop the D6 was played also completely
winning doesn't really matter The Rook
is attacked The Rook to see it was
played and now a beautiful finish by
Bishop captures on C5 saying if you got
from C7 I win your bishop and if you win
my Bishop I just play Rook to d8 with
check and now you either trade and I get
a queen or you move and I pick up the
free rook here uh both is uh completely
fine next I'm gonna move the Rook
promote the pawn to a queen that doesn't
really matter what white plays
everything is completely winning so yeah
after Bishop captures on C5 bookish
absolutely dominates this and absolutely
brutalize the study and this was not
Armageddon this was a classical game so
I mean imagine this in a classical game
this is not something you see very often
C7 and then D7 I mean this is a
classical game and it comes from from a
London system so that that's absolutely
absolutely beautiful so like I said
we're not going to discuss what's
happened in the other games because uh
some of the games are still being played
well I'm recording this but I will show
you this and if you can deduct a bit
more from this then you know I'm not
going to hold it against you but these
are the live ratings after uh eight
rounds of Norway chess uh gookish climbs
up all the way to number 13 in the world
so as you can see he jumped up four
places now he's at 27.43 absolutely
incredible so now he has three more uh
players to beat to reach top 10 and then
gukesh at his age will be in the in the
top 10 in the world he still has the to
overtaker a job of karakin and Rapport
but I mean he's already already there
with the with all the greats in the
world uh some of the other winners okay
Fab is still in plus 13 and we have
Nakamura and plus seven Anisha and plus
three Westland plus four bookish now on
plus seven
so everyone everyone's a winner here as
you can see okay we playing a different
tournament but also on plus seven
another back uh messing up a little bit
he's on -8 so you can see he dropped
from 21 to 24. what are you going to do
I mean it's the live rating so it
changes every day pretty much if you
play
uh yeah that's the game and a little bit
of extra info I mean look at this
position one more time this is classical
chess I I mean I'm absolutely stunned by
by this but you know I'm very glad that
it happened and that more more classical
games will uh reach positions like these
uh if um uh you know uh players really
do everything they can to when they try
they prepare well and they play you know
crazy openings that allow for such
positions to occur and bookish is one
such player and I'm always happy to
check out one of his games uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
I would like to thank David Kimura David
Gaspar and Ricky Johnson and the Hydra
agar for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this Splendid event until it
finishes uh so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day